it's it's so special to be you know
recognized alongside a group of people
that I love and all of my fellow social
creators yeah it's just you're up
against your little sister my big sister
yeah yeah I'm the little yeah which I
don't yeah I don't know how she feels I
mean we are sisters we're roommates we
spend every single day together
you know some friendly competition is
good it's
so special to be you know recognized
alongside a group of people that I love
and all of my fellow social creators
yeah it's just you're up against your
little sister my big sister yeah yeah
I'm the little yeah which I don't yeah I
don't know how she feels I mean we are
sisters we're roommates we spend every
single day together
you know some friendly competition is
good